[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in maurice jones drew nfl
network analyst he also uh is the rams
radio color analyst and a former running
back you can follow maurice jones
through on twitter at mjd thursday night
football continues this week jags
bengals exclusively on nfl network how
big was the rams win yesterday mojo
oh man first of all dan is so glad to be
back it's been too long you know it's
it's a beautiful thing our relationship
it's like we never talk and then once we
talk it's like we don't even
miss a beat but it was a huge win for
the rams i thought uh tom brady and the
buccaneers are a very talented team we
saw that we beat up on a lot of people
and they didn't have antonio brown or
jpp yesterday but the convincing win by
the rams offense was was
massie stafford looks really good
deshawn jackson got into the fold and
then
cooper cup has been lights out the the
last three weeks and i i mean just wait
until they get robert woods going and
you know other guys got tyler higby
going live yesterday which was really
nice and
i mean again it just it
seems like sean mcvay is just kind of
dialing up some really good plays that
are that are working really well right
now
barring injury
any
concerns um
[Music]
not really i think they have you know
this kind of uh
they're all about their stars in uh in
l.a right so you have matthew staffer
cooper cup and then defensively have
aaron donald and jalen ramsey they kind
of play but with them they everyone else
has a role after those guys
uh they're playing really well right now
very confident uh and they're practicing
well for what i'm hearing and
uh it's it's it's pretty good it's it's
a good uh mix of guys that are going
with good coaching and
uh it's gonna be exciting to see kind of
how they have they've hit the injury bug
a little bit a couple guys have been
nicked up but
they're doing a great job of keeping
guys healthy and getting guys back
how different is the offense or at least
the play calling with matthew stafford
as opposed to jared goff
uh it's very different but i think that
i think the biggest difference a lot of
people are going to say the arm talent i
think the biggest difference is matthew
stafford's experience right um yeah he
has a strong arm we get to the ball of
the yard but there was a couple times
yesterday where late in the play
uh he was checking the guys to a
different play right and it wasn't a
throw down the field it might have been
he saw a blitz and he checked to a quick
screen or he saw a blitz and he checked
into a quick pass or he saw they're
playing covers and he checked to a good
run and so his experience of seeing a
lot of defenses and knowing knowing what
people are doing and getting them out of
a bad play into a right place is kind of
what what's been like really getting
this team going and so i think mcveigh's
kind of giving him the the keys to the
car let him kind of do what he wants out
there uh in certain situations
aaron donald's fascinating because i
know we talk a lot about edge rushers i
just think when you have a quarterback
like tom brady you know a lot of these
quarterbacks who are pocket quarterbacks
the pressure you put up the middle now i
force them out of the pocket out of
their comfort zone
i mean it's hard to find guys like aaron
donald but man when you do there's just
nobody like him uh what what do you see
does he remind you of anybody you played
against
no not anyone i played against i think
the closest person you could think uh
that's similar to his skill set is john
randall
just quick off the ball
very strong explosive but the beautiful
thing about aaron donald where a lot of
other guys don't i mean
with his size and ability would say john
randall but he lines up all over the
line so you can't slide and protect am i
slides or protections to him because
sometimes he'll be on the right
sometimes they'll be on the left
sometimes in the middle he's all over
the place um and you know it's it's his
work ethic and his leadership that i
think
you know they they don't talk enough
about we always talk about his play but
being in part of the team and being
around the team a ton you see his
leadership come into play a ton and so
his attitude the way he goes about his
business the way he goes about his day
he's always uh ready to go and so you
know he finally got his sack against tom
brady a guy that he hasn't sacked in his
career which was good for him and uh it
was a huge play and a huge part of the
game there's sometimes dan and it's
crazy you won't hear aaron donald's name
for
three
three quarters
and 12 minutes of the game
and then he'll have a timely play at the
end of the game to end it and that's
kind of the that's the way he's been
like there's sometimes he'll dominate
the whole game there's other times
they'll do a great job of getting after
him and then next thing you know he
comes in in a crucial time and gets a
strip sack fumble the game's over
you know how this business works that
everybody wants to have a referendum
every monday that we know exactly what a
team is going to be like or a player is
going to be like after what you saw with
the buccaneers what would you say to
buccaneers fans after yesterday's
performance
are you are you really concerned
like they they're they're going to
stumble every team i don't think there's
going to be a team issue that's going to
go undefeated i mean even as good as the
rams look they still have to go through
their nfc west play which is a very
tough division
um after looking at that roster and
watching the guys play and my concern no
not at all i mean
you you didn't have antonio brown like i
said earlier jpp's banged up
um
and you're getting reps when those guys
go down your young guys are getting
better and getting reps to play which is
going to help you in the long run
and so for me it's like wow like these
they're going to be a tough opponent it
was a big game it's going to have some
playoff implications possibly a home
playoff game here at sofi but i mean the
bucks went on the road last year won it
all so what's the difference
are you older than brady
uh body wise probably
but you know he has a couple years old
he i mean
he's from the great outdoors what do you
expect he's
he's phenomenal can i say this because i
know we're gonna head to this i have to
the interferon is like the greatest soap
opera ever right you have this beautiful
relationship with bill belichick and tom
brady
and it's like it turned toxic the last
couple years and then they had this
crazy breakup and it was just like so
cra and then you finally get a chance to
go back and like see your ex but what's
your what's your you're with your new
boo now like i can't wait to see this
double digits happening on sunday night
like it is the best thing ever i i you
can't draw up anything like this whoever
and then the best part is they did it
early in the season too i wish it was a
little bit later i wish it was like
november right where it's a little cold
and in foxborough and yeah all that but
man this is this is going to be some of
the greatest football we've had every
sunday night game has been awesome the
one last night was crazy aaron rodgers
goes back you know he hasn't been
playing well he's beefing with his his
girlfriend and then the niners tried to
go get him and it's just like it's so
mad and you saw matt laflore so upset
like it is so dramatic that it's like
the best tv ever it's it's it's
literally like a soap opera for like the
next you know three months four months
this is gonna be amazing i can't wait
it's it's just so much drama there's so
many storylines it's so amazing you know
i just didn't love it i got brady is
brady
eight years older than you
uh eight years yeah wow
i'm young man i'm still i'm still young
and hip and by the way
what am i going to be able to get in the
movie with you and adam sandler right
when are we going to be able to make
this thing work i i want to get in i
just want a cameo oh there's so many
other running backs
there's so many other running backs
though that are on the list mojo it's
not about running backs it's about my
relationship with you
and your relationship with adam sandler
you see what i'm saying yeah but you
know i got derek henry wants to be in
the movie no darry henry he's still
playing he don't get to do all that
stuff he doesn't have the history that
me and you have don't don't bring this
new hotness up i've been with you for a
long time yeah you know who else paulie
matt forte remember fred taylor called
oh fred taylor once in a moment don't
give me but but they're not as
consistent as i've been with you
right you've been consistent together
for years don't do this
don't throw our relationship away for
like some short
some short like hot date or whatever you
know you guys have going on this has
been consistent i've been loyal brian
westbrook
so
many yes mclovin remember sandler had
that spot for a slightly undersized
running back and it went to darren
sproles oh that's right sproles got the
roll yes sorry mojo
listen that's the problem you you got
you're not thinking about me right now i
don't like that like i'm trying to
expand my career as well
i'm trying to i'm always trying to get
better right and the next step is being
with you in the movie i just want to
stand up i mean you you're the movie
with shaq what how hard is it not to get
me in there
wait what is shaq really doing that i
haven't done wow
wow you're calling out shaq
i mean i'm not calling out shaq i'm just
saying you know i would like to be in a
movie as well
all right i'll see what i can do
all right thank you i'll put it okay how
about this rams go to the super bowl
you're in
well you know what i i would take that
but i literally have no control of what
they do
but i like the ram so much that i'm with
that let's do it all right great to talk
to you as always mojo
always good to talk to you as well thank
you man that's maurice jones drew nfl
network analyst rams color
analyst on radio and former nfl running
back